but recently it was in the mainstream
media that somebody was some
naturopathic healer was talking about
drinking something that was disgusting
according to mainstream you know and
just americans pp standards
i tried my own pee
i tried i tried you're in therapy
you're in therapy yeah i am you're in i
am there you're in therapy you can do
your you're doing you're in therapy yeah
no my friend davina
has been doing the one i mentioned
earlier with something
no straight vodka nope no drinking
before because what color is your urine
should it be a certain color because
mine is neon yellow is that okay
yeah maybe you don't have a uti when you
do it it's supposed to glow in the dark
because
mine is uranium
it's uranium
mine might be washer fluid actually how
do we feel how did it go well i'm i've
it's been a week now okay almost so i'm
doing it to fully do it great
thank you
emily's face i'm 65 years old
to make it even crazier
uh
so my friend davina who i i have to give
another shout out to because she's the
one that introduced me to michelle for
combo but also she's been doing posts
about urine therapy because
she follows people on instagram and then
i started following some people on
instagram and then there was one guy
named nick caputo who was on this
podcast um i think it's called the best
you ever had i think is what the podcast
is called but anyway he's urine
everything like talks about the benefits
of it and how we are just been
conditioned to believe that this is
waste it's not waste it's literally just
your filtered blood
so and it's got stem cells in it it's
got
uh homemade i've been peed on so maybe
that's why it looks so good and it's a
very intimate thing it does help it's
anti-aging 100 but but what is why is
that why do i want a clown on it is it
is it i'm conditioned to go pee-pee's
bad yeah it comes out of a it's crazy
yeah it it why am i not we know how on
board why am i not on board
because here's the thing the eating the
placenta which is a big that's a huge
thing too
but i i'm not sold it's like it is all
the toxic waste from and grace will know
the answer to this but like it's the
toxic waste that
you're taking so that it doesn't get
into your baby and people like well
we'll wolves do what dogs do it they eat
their placenta
to uh basically uh so that predators
don't smell blood
that's why they they don't eat it they
don't eat it for the vitamin b yeah i've
not done too much research into so when
predators eat their placenta after birth
it's so that there's not blood that
can pick up on yeah so if you're in a
hospital or whatever and you have a
placenta you don't need to eat it
there's no pred there's no tigers around
that's right but okay so i fully had
pill santa this morning
was that a smoothie no i know
they're like i put my placenta in my
smoothie i'm like that's just all the
mercury and bull and extra iron and
chemicals that your body was trying to
clean out yeah well with
it's a with urine and again i just am
studying this now i'm just like so and i
so i and i always prefer
it's hard for me to not make jokes i'm
trying i want you to make jokes i know
i'm trying to not i'm trying to be
respectful of this okay you can make fun
but also that's how we normalize things
too right right
to drink your own urine you're undoing
the benefits so i might still be there
[Music]
[Applause]